bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce jeudi 27 avril pour la première
fois grâce à une thérapie génique un
grave déficit immunitaire qui obligeait
les bébés à vivre dans une bulle a été
corrigé les bébés sont sortis ils vont
bien nous en parlerons avec le
professeur alain fischer & rica tandis
que l' enquête judiciaire sur les
conditions du naufrage du pétrolier
erika s'élargit une équipe de france 2
avec patrick fandio a pu rencontrer en
exclusivité le propriétaire de l'erika
l'un des plus puissants chefs
d'entreprises françaises jean luc
lagardère comparaissent est aujourd'hui
en correctionnelle pour abus de biens
sociaux à la veille du 11e congrès du
front national de jean marie le pen
enquête chez des militants désenchanté
et puis du football après une victoire à
l'arraché hier soir sur la slovénie le
sélectionneur roger lemerre de
maintenant composer la liste des 22
sélectionnés pour le championnat
d'europe
alors pour france 2 la chaîne du
téléthon c'est évidemment un vrai grand
plaisir que de l'annoncer la thérapie
génique ça marche
un premier succès un premier succès
mondial apporte en effet la preuve de
l'efficacité de ce nouveau mode de
traitement et ce sont des bébés qui en
profite
il était atteint d'un grave déficit
immunitaire héréditaire et c'était à
priori condamné à vie dans une bulle
stérile pour éviter les microbes
la thérapie génique mise au point par
professeur alain fischer et son équipe à
l'hôpital necker appert à à paris leur a
permis de rompre cet enfermement
explications et jean daniel flaysakier
michel levasseur
c'était en novembre dernier et oui pour
le petit land et n'avait vu de paris que
cette bulle à l'hôpital necker
wilko n'avait aucune défense labarelle
chaque germe ou parasites étaient une
menace pour son existence tout cela à
court d'une anomalie génétique à l'état
normal en effet dans notre moelle
osseuse existe des cellules dites
précurseurs
ce sont en quelque sorte d entraîneur de
boxe elle stimule les cellules de
défense qu'on appelle les lymphocytes
pour qu'elle reconnaisse attaque et tue
les microbes mais si wilko il manquait
un gène et l'entraîneur ne pouvait pas
faire travailler les lymphocytes
à chaque fois ce sont les microbes qui
gagnait le combat alors l'équipe d'alain
fischer a décidé de réparer l'erreur de
la nature les chercheurs ont prélevé de
la moelle osseuse chez où il coache
quatre autres enfants
ils ont mis en culture les cellules
présentes dans cette moelle avec des
virus
transformé en livreur et ces virus sont
allés déposer dans les cellules
précurseurs le gènes manquants
il ne restait plus qu'à espérer que
l'entraîneur puisse se réveiller et
stimuler les lymphocytes
quinze jours après l'opération de wilko
pour le téléthon 99 jane birkin est allé
rencontrer alain fischer
drake
les sept enfants comme vas voir il va
sortir des et hôpital en combien de
temps
si les choses se passent bien au bout de
quelques mois on verra
il pourra peut-être sortir de la bulle
et wilco est sorti comme les quatre
autres enfants et avec un an de recul
pour deux d'entre eux il ya beaucoup de
raisons d'être optimiste on paye assez d
en face à la maison il joue avec les
autres enfants conduit directement
normal sauf préfet qu'elle était
enceinte à ils sont encore obligés de
venir nous voir à l'hôpital necker pour
s'assurer qu'il ya une suite positive de
ces événements cinq petits prisonniers
ont déjà réussi à échapper à la bulle
et l'histoire me masson pas s'arrêter là
professeur fisher et bravo merci
d'ailleurs jacques chirac a salué lui
une impressionnante lui casser les
premiers succès de thérapie génique ils
perdent un immense espoir présent et
l'avenir sentiment d'admiration de
reconnaissance auquel il associe
l'inserm une association française
contre les myopathies
alors d'abord comment vont les cinq le
bd écouter quatre d'entre eux vont
vraiment très bien
trois d'entre eux d'ailleurs ont un
recul suffisant pour avoir regagné leurs
domiciles vivre une vie normale auprès
de leurs parents a été traitée encore
relativement récemment donc c'est trop
tôt pour se prononcer complètement même
si les résultats sont prometteurs pour
un 5ème les choses sont un petit peu
moins net il est encore hospitalisé vous
devons attendre pour savoir ce qui va se
passer
alors j'en ai fais à qui il faisait
allusion aux vaccinations ils peuvent
être vaccinés ils auront la même
croissance y aura pas de tirer de
conséquences
jusqu'à présent ça se passe bien leur
croissance est normal y en a même acquis
un champion de la croissance il pense
qu'il n'a rien à voir avec son
traitement mais qui est plutôt en avance
pour son âge et il n'y a aucune raison
que leur croissance leur développement
soit perturbé tant que l'effet du
traitement persiste est ce qu'il y à
d'autres thérapies en cours pour
d'autres bébés avec cette maladie non
nous avons terminé avec ses cinq
patients un premier essai pour une
première évaluation de ce que ce type de
traitement pouvait faire naturellement
compte tenu des résultats positifs nous
envisageons maintenant d'entreprendre un
traitement d'une nouvelle série de
patients que nous espérons conduire dans
les prochaines semaines connaître
maladie en pour l'instant pour la même
maladie c'est important de conforter ses
résultats par l'évaluation chez d'autres
patients
mais naturellement nous travaillons mais
d'autres équipes de par le monde
travaillons à la mise au point de
traitements analogue pour des maladies
voisine d'autres déficiences graves du
système
hyper ont les mêmes conséquences et il y
a des raisons d'espérer que à peu près
les mêmes procédés thérapeutiques seront
également efficace vous y travaillent
est ce que ce sont des traitements
définitif ou est ce qu'à un moment donné
il faudra recommencer
c'est une question très importante car
il faut pas susciter de l'espoir qui
serait illégitime
nous savons donc au bout d'un an le
traitement peut être efficace et
corriger complètement la maladie du
système immunitaire de telle façon que
les enfants se défendent bien contre
toute forme d'infection mais nous ne
savons pas pour combien de temps cet
effet sera obtenue il est possible il ya
même des raisons scientifiquement
déterminé de penser qu'avec au bout d'un
certain temps de mois ou des années où
des dizaines d'années ce serait mieux
des dizaines d'années les faits s'épuise
et qu'il faille envisager à nouveau de
traiter ces patients
ça implique qu'ils soient surveillés les
familles sont au courant elle participe
pleinement de façon formidable c'est
l'occasion de rendre hommage à cet essai
assez première traite ses premiers
essais de traitement pour ce type de
maladie mais on ne peut certainement pas
conclure à jour aujourd'hui à ce que
l'effet observé actuellement soit
définitive
est-ce que la technique que vous avez
utilisé on peut l'imaginer pour donner
des ordres d'autres cellules de défense
dans d'autres manifs par ce rhumatisme
affections thyroïdiennes aux autres ça
c'est un peu plus compliqué c'est clair
que si on cible les cellules du système
immunitaire on peut imaginer à terme
mais vraiment à terme de traiter
d'autres maladies notamment auto immune
rhumatismales vous évoquez les maladie
des articulations
il faudra du temps les problèmes posés
sont beaucoup plus complexes
ce que nous pouvons faire dans une
certaine mesure aujourd'hui dans une
situation très privilégiée en fait ne
peut pas s'appliquer demain en tous les
cas immédiatement à beaucoup d'autres
pathologies il faut rester prudent sur
ce plan néanmoins à travers ses
résultats et puis des progrès à venir de
plein de gens
la recherche bat son plein partout enfin
partout partout un certain nombre
d'endroits de par le monde
on peut espérer que les progrès
viendront mais il faudra du temps mais
grâce à vous grâce à votre équipe à
necker il ya un immense espoir d'un
monde la publication d'un ca yan tu vas
certainement attiser encore la
concurrence n'ont que la concurrence est
saine
dans ce cadre c'est clair que c'est un
message positif pour la thérapie génique
qui est un peu souffert ces derniers
temps d'un certain nombre de deux
mauvaise passe ou deux
choses un peu désagréable qui se sont
passées c'est un message d'espoir mais
en même temps il faut le placer dans sa
juste perspective
c'est à dire ce qui a été obtenu c'est
la correction complète des anomalies
observées dans une maladie donnée au
bout d'un an
transposer ça dans le temps comme on l'a
vu tout à l'heure où transposer ça à
d'autres maladies nécessitent temps
travail et prudence prudence
alors on va le faire ensemble parce
qu'on était souvent partenaires sur le
téléthon c'est grâce à l'argent du
téléthon en grande partie alors il faut
saluer les donateurs à votre équipe
l'afm quand il ya beaucoup de gens qui
méritent d'être saluées je veux pas être
trop long mais c'est clair que c'est un
travail d'équipé
beaucoup de gens ont participé jour au
moins citer le nom de marina cavazzana
calvo qui a été absolument qu'on a
entendu tout à l'heure qui était
absolument clé dans la réalisation de
cet essai clinique et des recherches
pendant 7 ans qui ont précédé le début
des travaux
ces travaux ont été faits avec l'aide de
nombreux partenaires
alors vous avez cité l'afm et du
téléthon largement contribué à toutes
les phases et en particulier dans la
phase thérapeutique mais il faut aussi y
associer les les fonds de recherche
publique en particulier l'inserm
mais aussi l assistance publique des
hôpitaux de paris l'université enfin
notre cadre de travail de tous les jours
l'hôpital université l'inserm tous
contribuent et avec l'afm donc nous
avons besoin de tous pour avancer merci
beaucoup mais bravo encore le conflit
engagé par les internes des hôpitaux
pour obtenir une revalorisation de leurs
salaires mais aussi une amélioration des
conditions de l'exercice de leur métier
est peut-être en passe de s'achever un
texte a été élaboré hier soir tard avec
les conseillers de martine aubry au
ministère de la solidarité et dans les
vingt-cinq chu en grève en france des
assemblées générales doivent se
prononcer dans la soirée sur ce texte
reportage et midi dansant françois
privat et philippe ritaine à poitiers
une salle de garde pour décor et dans le
rôle du défenseur du protocole d'accord
un délégué syndical
des résidents c'est évident que leur
propre sécurité veux pas m me met en
place comme ça parce qu'il faut plus
demande l'organisation est importante
ils demandent un délai de trois ans de
l'autre des internes pour la plupart pas
franchement convaincu si on parle du
repos de sécurité on voit bien que ce ne
pourra être appliquée que grâce à l'est
à des créations de bosses pas j'ai quand
même le sentiment qu'il faut parler plus
sérieusement si ce n'est si ce n'est en
chiffres d'avoir une une promesse ou des
propositions sur des créations de à
l'hôpital finalement la grève est
reconduite à une large majorité
cela vaut bien une petite photo dans le
journal réunion privée entre interne à
clamart ici on se pose les mêmes
questions qu'à poitiers hier les
internautes obtenu la promesse d'un
repos compensateur après 24 heures de
garde
le paiement des heures effectuées le
week end et une petite augmentation de
leur rémunération
aucun engagement écrit cependant alors
certains internes veulent maintenir la
pression
les textes sont trop flous et nous
permettent pas de garantir en fait la
certitude de l'obtention des points qui
ont été soulevés ici on est obligé de
faire la grève des soins des malades on
la fera pas de gaieté de coeur mais on
la frappe pour obtenir gain de cause
mon point et mauvais points continuent
vont être distribués ce soir et demain
les internes doivent en effet se
prononcer en assemblée générale sur le
protocole d'accord qui leur est proposé
en attendant la grève se poursuit un peu
partout dans la confusion concernant la
réforme des lycées la méthode jack lang
se démarque de celle de son prédécesseur
le nouveau ministre de l'éducation veut
aider dit-il les professeurs à
reconquérir la fierté de même et s'il
maintient certaines mesures prises par
claude allègre
parmi les innovations pédagogiques il
renonce en revanche à réduire les
emplois du temps des élèves annonce de
nouveaux crédits et renforce
l'enseignement littéraire reportage d'un
bélier a d'abord ri avec joseph beuys
tic avec jack lang rien ne se perd tout
se transforme
après un mois de consultations tous
azimuts loin d'enterrer la réforme de
son prédécesseur le ministre de
l'éducation veut au contraire garder
l'esprit du projet allègre il y reprend
d'ailleurs deux mesures phares l'aide
individualisée en classe de seconde
mise en place il ya un an elle est
maintenue pour la prochaine
entrez les travaux personnels encadrés
en expérimentation depuis cette année
dans 200 établissements
ils seront généralisées en janvier 2001
des mesures que les tenons des réformes
ont accueilli favorablement
nous avions demandé un différé dans la
mise en place des tpe en même temps
qu'une généralisation donc nous avons
satisfaction sur les déboires comme nous
avons satisfaction sur la pérennisation
de la d'individualités qui sont les deux
points durs de la réforme des lycées sur
lesquels nous étions avec d'autres
mobiliser la réforme de claude allègre
avait été sévèrement critiqué soupçonné
de vouloir alléger les programmes son
successeur veut rassurer professeurs et
parents et renforce donc l'enseignement
des matières littéraires et des langues
étrangères en première et en terminale
dès la rentrée une demi-heure
hebdomadaire de français de
mathématiques seront également ajoutés
au programme de seconde
une mesure en direction du snes
principal syndicat s'opposer à la
réforme allègre certaines disciplines
qui était très menacées comme les
langues anciennes et langues régionales
certaines langues à faible diffusion
vont retrouver de la vie et c'est
positif les enseignements artistiques
aussi sans doute mais on n'a pas encore
franchi toutes les étapes
claude allègre s'était mis les
enseignants à dos jack lang veut se les
mettre dans la poche
en attendant le vote du budget 2001 dans
lequel promet-il seront prévu des
créations de postes le parquet de paris
vient de délivrer un réquisitoire
supplétif d'un enquête judiciaire sur le
pétrolier erika cette enquête pourrait
viser la société rina qui avaient
contrôlé le navire avant le naufrage
pour france 2 patrick fandio guillaume
faudra à londres viennent de rencontrer
le propriétaire de l'erika dans cette
interview une première exclusivité
celui ci entouré d'avocats paraît très
embarrassé devant l'ampleur du désastre
et affirme avoir demandé des contrôles
préalables
il a fini par tolérer la présence de la
caméra
voici donc à quoi ressemble propriétaire
de l'erika en jeune homme d'affaires
italien
il a 35 ans et vit à londres ils
auraient préféré rester un petit
armateurs distraite
mais le naufrage du bateau a change is f
a été une expérience une expérience très
dramatique
pour moi cher navire ce fut un choc très
personnel je suis très touchée très
peiné par toute cette pollution
ap set up de france des regrets et de
l'amertume
l'homme se dit ruiné sa spécialité son
business comme on dit ici c'est le
rachat et la gestion de vieux pétrolière
au large du port militaire dargouth
temps sicile nous avons retrouvé il ya
quelques semaines un bateau appartenant
à giuseppe savarese le maria s est
bloqué par les autorités italiennes
dupuis 4 mois même pavillon même âge que
l'erika et là aussi un équipage indien
il est en grève car le capitaine et ses
trente marins réclame plusieurs
centaines de milliers de dollars
d'arriérés de salaire à monsieur savard
est il doit payer pour ça non seulement
pour le travail que nous avons fait mais
aussi pour l'agonie mentale qui nous
infligent il doit payer pour ça les
marins du mari as ne se font pas
d'illusions ils savent bien que monsieur
savarese est un homme endetté presque
insolent va tout occupé à la préparation
de sa défense dans le dossier de l'erika
chez son avocat
il nous montre tous les certificats de
contrôle du navire
tous sont en retz je n'arrive pas à
comprendre s'il y avait des défauts
aussi important personne ne l'a remarqué
je pense que c'était un accident et
c-max à un accident je ne suis pas en
position à dire pourquoi j'aime ça mais
c'est sans doute parce osé la corrosion
je pense qu'il ya eu une multitude de
facteurs
le propriétaire de l'erika dit attendre
avec sérénité les conclusions des
enquêtes sur les causes du naufrage
demain ici à londres giuseppe savarese
serait interrogé par 25 avocats et
experts français
le propriétaire de l'erika déjà rodé sa
défense si quelqu'un est responsable du
naufrage
ce n'est certainement pas lui
en quête de patrick fandio guillaume
faudra la société nationale corse
méditerranée sncm a annulé toutes ses
traversées entre la corse et le
continent aujourd'hui annulation forcée
en raison d'une grève du personnel de la
compagnie maritime public qui veut faire
pression sur l'assemblée de corse
car celle ci examine en ce moment même
le cahier des charges de la desserte
maritime de l'île
reportage jean bernard schmidt et
christian leroux surtout rallier le plus
de monde possible à la cause la cause
c'est la défense d'un service public que
les marins assurant les liaisons corse
continent estiment menacée deux jours de
grève à la sncm la société nationale
corse méditerranée une mobilisation pour
faire pression sur les élus de l'île qui
commencent à débattre des subventions
aux transports maritimes car depuis 25
ans pour pallier le handicap de
l'insularité une aide financière
soutient les liaisons avec le continent
jusqu'à présent seule la sncm en a
bénéficié
aujourd'hui tout doit être renégociée et
cette fois ci il y à des compagnies
concurrentes sur la ligne de départ de
l'ouverture à la concurrence a toujours
été gênante partout dans le monde et
qu'il s'agisse à paris et rome à moscou
à tokyo je crois que la concurrence par
cet homme
quelques difficultés h&r et de la
compétition celle-ci ne voudrais surtout
pas perdre
c'est la sncm la compagnie publique dont
les bateaux sont aujourd'hui bloqués à
quai longtemps en situation de quasi
monopole elle est accusée d'être lourde
à gérer et dirigeants estiment surtout
ne pas avoir les mêmes contraintes que
les autres
nous desservons la corse toute l'année
tous les jours nous le desservons avec
un pavillon français qui ne bénéficient
pas des mêmes aides que les pavillons
concurrents et nous la desservons avec
des navires modernes principal rival de
la sncm la compagnie corsica ferries sur
le marché depuis 96 elle réclame
aujourd'hui sa part des subventions qui
ont atteint l'an dernier plus de 710
millions de francs qu'on a donné plus
d'argent que ce qui était nécessaire
pour assurer les obligations de service
public
et cette différence peut permettre à
celui qui détient cet argent de fausser
le jeu de la concurrence
en décembre dernier le débat sur les
subventions aérienne avait été
particulièrement houle
les élus entendent que les choses se
passent plus calmement cette fois ci la
banque centrale européenne a augmenté
son taux directeur d'un quart de point à
3 75% mais cela n'a pas empêché l'euro
de continuer sa plongée sous les 0 91 $
ce soir jean luc lagardère devant le
tribunal correctionnel de paris celui
qui codirige sera bientôt la troisième
entreprise mondiale de défense et
d'aéronautique et prévenu d'abus de
biens sociaux élus approchaient un
système compliqué de rémunération
illicite
l'explication et comptes rendus
d'audience avec dominique verdeilhan et
eric de l'agneau il n'est pas agréable
de se retrouver ici concède jean-luc
lagardère le chef d'entreprise est un
habitué des conseils d'administration
par des audiences correctionnelles
à ses côtés son staff son bras droit le
pdg d'airbus mais aussi son fils arnaud
sont venus soutenir ses ennuis
judiciaires jean luc lagardère les doit
à un homme alain géniteau depuis
plusieurs années ce petit actionnaire se
fait une spécialité de lancer les
procédures contre différents chefs
d'entreprise technologie espace défense
communication la galaxie lagardère et
elle entachée de vices de forme pdg
d'hachette jean luc lagardère est
actionnaire à hauteur de 3,2 pour cent p
dg de matra il est actionnaire à hauteur
de 4,2 pour cent en 88
il crée une société de gestion argile il
en détient 82% son fils ayant les 18
autres durant quatre ans achètent et
matra vont verser 0,2 pour cent de leur
chiffre d'affaires en échange argile va
prendre en charge les salaires les
charges sociales et les frais divers
d'une quinzaine de cadres quand on met
un genou à terre synergie stratégie de
management d'un côté abus de bien social
rémunérations occultes de l'autre jamais
dans une audience le fossé entre le
monde de la finance et la justice n'aura
paru aussi grand je ne suis ni un
juriste ni un financier dit jean luc
lagardère mais un ingénieur mon but est
de gérer proprement des sociétés tout en
réalisant des bénéfices
l'infraction est bien réalisé monsieur
lagardère en était bien conscient assène
le procureur qui dévoilera demain après
midi ses réquisitions la présidente rpr
du conseil régional de la guadeloupe
lucette michaux chevry mise en examen
pour favoritisme et détournement de
fonds publics il s'agit d'une enquête
sur des pots-de-vin qui auraient été
versés lors de la passation de marchés
publics concernant la réfection des
lycées en guadeloupe
l'un des chef nationaliste corse charles
joseph pierre y comparaît jusqu'à demain
pour association de malfaiteurs en vue
d'actes de terrorisme devant le tribunal
correctionnel de paris
il y a cinq autres prévenus avec lui
charles pieri avait été arrêté en sept
ans 98 il est l'ancien secrétaire
national da concoules à ce que l'on
appelait la vitrine du flnc canal
historique qu'on avait trouvé chez lui
une très importante cache d'armes
agnès vahramian hébert numério était à
l'audience ce qu'il reste de la
concurrence et monter à paris une
vingtaine tout au plus de militants
venus écouter leur ancien leader charles
pieri qui pour la première fois depuis
son arrestation consentent à s'expliquer
il y a un an et demi les policiers
l'interpellent sans conviction dans une
affaire de meurtre
mais c'est leur jour de chance il trouve
à son domicile un arsenal 11 pistolets
de fusils d'assaut des cagoules 70
bâtons de dynamite et des notes de
repérage sur des bâtiments publics à
l'époque charles pieri et secrétaire
national de la consulta vitrine légale
du flnc
que faisaient ces armes de guerre chez
lui elle visait dit il à le protéger
il avait autour de lui des gens qui
étaient destinés à sa protection sans
que celui ci ait n'est d'ailleurs
forcément
un quelconque eu regard sur la manière
dont il fait protéger est-ce qu'on se
défend avec de la dynamite
peut-être qu'on ne se défendent pas avec
de la dynamite mais est-ce qu'ils
étaient informés que dans les sacs qu'on
lui a donné il y avait de la dynamique
charles pieri fait valoir des menaces
qu'il aurait reçus en 96 il avait bien
été gravement blessées dans un attentat
à la voiture piégée mais la présidente
du tribunal s'étonne encore de la
présence d'autant d'armes
elle évoque alors ses liens avec le flnc
chant pieri dément à chaque question
forcément gênante charles pieri d'abord
souri puis marmonne il fait mine de
réfléchir en fait gagner du temps et
quand on lui demande si quelqu'un
d'autre que l'efsf lnc peut avoir
apporté ses armes et bien là il est très
embarrassé mais il ne se démonte pas
expliquant qu'avec ses activités le jour
eh bien il n'aurait tout simplement pas
le temps d'être un activiste la nuit en
plein centre de grenoble vers 10 heures
ce matin une attaque à main armée avec
tirs de mitraillettes et de
lance-roquettes a provoqué la mort d'un
convoyeur de fonds celui ci faisait
partie de l'équipe d'un faucon blindé de
la société transval qui venait de
quitter la banque de france grenobloise
commentaires thierry curtet le commando
était très déterminé
il n'a pas hésité à ouvrir le feu en
plein centre ville le pour vous re
montait une contre allée à petite
vitesse vers 10 heures ce matin
il revenait de la banque de france
lorsque deux hommes masqués le bleu ils
ont entendu trois coups de feu je me
suis penché sur mon achat potage deux
premiers étages et dès que je me suis
penché j'ai vu un monsieur habillé tout
en bleu de travail assez gros il avait
maintenu une mitraillette puis l'avait
un tube i s'est étirée il se rapprochait
du camion il a tiré sur les vitres tac
tac tac il a tiré plusieurs fois puis
dit la dew ouvre au fils de [ __ ] et des
crédits a été mis sur le côté a battu
veut pas ouvrir et là il a changé son
son machin puis d'un autre gars qui est
avec lui un autre complice qui était sur
le côté
la boum boum moi j'ai frappé c'est les
gens je rentrais puis j'appelle la
police coire les truands tire trois fois
au lance roquettes
il tue un convoyeur blesse les deux
autres et parvient à s'enfuir à bord
d'une mer 21 conduite par un troisième
complice si ce véhicule que les
policiers retrouvent incendie dans un
parking
la préfecture de l'isère à ce soir
constitué une cellule de crise
dans le gard la roque sur cèze les
sauveteurs ont repêché aujourd'hui le
corps du plongeur qui avait tenté de
secourir la petite fille de 6 ans
disparu dans la rivière la cèze samedi
dernier l'enfant n'a toujours pas été
retrouvé un accident spectaculaire à
calais où un car ferry l'aquitaine de la
compagnie transmanche stena line a
heurté un quai en accostant
manifestement trop brutalement
trente-huit personnes ont été blessées m
blessé légèrement à tunis le journaliste
et militant des droits de l'homme
taoufik ben brik après avoir suspendu sa
grève de la faim a décidé de la
reprendre la surveillance policière
autour de son domicile a pourtant été
légèrement allégé mais le journaliste
avec l'homme toujours ses droits
fondamentaux sud allait devenir et ceux
d' exercer librement son métier commenté
jérôme ni message i d'urgence de taoufik
ben brik à l'elysée sa soeur najet c'est
un message de sortie verbale et il m'a
dit nous le transmet cas monsieur chirac
finalement elle ne rencontrera que l'un
des collaborateurs du président m'a dit
en effet que monsieur chirac titre est
sensible à la sphère de temps pour une
brique et il ya on essaye de faire
quelque chose pourtant pire je suis
monsieur chirac suit de très près la
sphère de temps favori
hier dès leur arrivée aux abords du
domicile du gréviste de la faim des
journalistes françaises et une
délégation de reporter sans frontières
sont brutalisés par la police
le tournage est interrompu parmi les
journalistes
julia free cattier du journal la croix
dont ben brik est le correspondant à
tunis je ne crois pas que ce soit un
dérapage
d'ailleurs s'il y avait vraiment il y
avait des policiers très correct et
d'autres policiers qui étaient
visiblement des classeurs
et qui étaient là pour vraiment casser
du matériel et et violenté les personnes
aujourd'hui la police n'interdit plus
l'accès à la maison de ben brik et sa
ligne téléphonique a été rétablie mais
le journaliste poursuit sa grève de la
faim pour avoir des nouvelles de son
frère arrêté hier jusqu'à aujourd'hui
mon frère chez elle à qui on lui a cassé
le nez refait pas où il est j'ai une
relation presque de deux jumeaux avec
lui je crèverai pour lui sous la
pression de ses amis
taoufik ben brik a accepté de continuer
à prendre le minimum vital
un peu de lait et de tisanes sucrées en
iran les deux derniers grands journaux
réformistes encore publiées dont celui
dirigé par le frère du président khatami
ont été fermées aujourd'hui par les
religieux conservateurs les réformistes
se trouvent ainsi privés de voie à une
semaine du deuxième tour des élections
qu'ils ont pourtant déjà d'ores et déjà
remporté moins de sept mois après
l'accident nucléaire au japon dans l'
usine de tokaimura un deuxième employé
vient de décéder des suites d'une
contamination à laquelle il faut le
rappeler furent exposés plus de 400
personnes à tchernobyl en ukraine 14 ans
après l'explosion d'un des réacteurs les
environs immédiats de la centrale
demeure totalement interdit les plantes
le sol l'eau tout est radioactif le site
est devenu un lieu d'expérimentation
unique au monde pour essayer de
comprendre l'évolution de
l'environnement de telles circonstances
mais aussi pour tenter d'établir des
règles de prévention
voyez le reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux à tchernobyl louis carzou
philippe du repos et andré navarri 1 km
à l'ouest de la centrale de tchernobyl
c'était l'une des plus belles forêts
d'ukraine jusqu'à l'accident
cette zone s'est appelé par la suite la
forêt rousse parce que les arbres ont
commencé à roussir la radioactivité
augmente très rapidement
et là évidemment il faut pas rester très
longtemps puisque en l'espace d'une
dizaine d'heures en prendrait la la
limite de dose annuelle
voilà la forêt rousse une centaine
d'hectares littéralement soufflée par
les radiations
quatorze ans plus tard à laboratoire
unique pour jean marc perez et valéry
kashparov tous ces arbres ont été
replantés depuis la catastrophe mais à
la hauteur de leurs racines
toutes sortes de déchets contaminés ont
été enterrés dans plus de 800 tranchées
dont on ignore aujourd'hui le tracé
exact
seule certitude cette zone recèle des
taux très élevés de césium le strontium
et permet d'observer la lente migration
les radioéléments dans la nature elle
permet aussi de comprendre un grand
nombre de phénomènes et ces phénomènes
compris on pourra prédire pour l'avenir
un petit peu ce qu'il se passe dans
d'autres zones qui sont un petit peu
moins contaminés car en l'état actuel
des connaissances les chercheurs
français et ukrainiens avouent leur
impuissance devant cette contamination
tellement forte que même une pomme de
pain devient une menace
on ne pourra jamais revenir se promener
ici les arbres qui poussent actuellement
sur la tranche est on exactement le même
niveau de contamination que les arbres
enfouis il y à 14 ans qu'à voler le
niveau de contamination est vraiment
très élevés à tel point que l'on se
demande s'il ne vaudrait pas mieux tout
arraché pour ne pas se retrouver avec
une deuxième forêt rousse ou brasilia
de fait les rares vestiges de la forêt
russe continue d'affoler les appareils
de mesure à tel point que français et
ukrainiens ont renoncé à employer des
appareils de pointe dans cette zone
trop coûteux car il faudrait les jeter
aujourd'hui leur principal souci est la
contamination à travers les nappes
phréatiques et les eaux de ruissellement
de la rivière pripyat en bordure de la
forêt aujourd'hui et pour encore
longtemps
aux philippines un contact a été établi
avec les rebelles islamistes qui ont
pris en otage 21 touristes aucune
opération commando sur une île en
malaisie tous les captifs sont en vie se
porte bien affirment les autorités de
manille les négociations seraient en
cours
demain à paris le 11e congrès du front
national de jean marie le pen s'ouvrira
dans un climat plutôt désenchanté la
scission opérée par bruno mégret a
laissé des traces
et si jean marie le pen est assuré
d'être réélu président du front national
chez les militants on se sent un peu
esseulé comme l'ont constaté arnaud
bouteille thierry breton dans leur
enquête à lire depuis des mois ils
répètent les mêmes gestes mais se
sentent de plus en plus seul la crise a
laissé des traces au front national les
militants colleurs d'affichés ne se
bousculent plus à se cacher c'est
évident à 9h dans n'importe quel
mouvement politique qu'aurait subi la
même session que nous l'aurions moins de
militants avant la scission le siège
départemental était l'un des plus actifs
aujourd'hui les bureaux sont vides 50%
de militants en moins c'est autant de
cotisations qui ne rentrent plus la
fédération connaît un déficit et devra
peut-être vendre ce local difficile dans
ces conditions de préparer les élections
municipales de constituer des listes
mais on tient à se montrer confiant en
répétant que le militant égaré reviendra
tôt ou tard à la maison je pense pas que
par rapport à l'analyse qui va faire ils
puissent avoir une autre direction que
la nôtre très sincèrement
ou alors il faut tout remettre en
question est ce qu'un front national ça
on peut pas le faire l'association des
retraités du front national ne veut
aucun changement politique
les retraités constituent aujourd'hui la
tranche d'âge majoritaire au sein des
militants du front
bruno gollnisch le sait alors ils
n'hésitent pas animer leur réunion ce
sont des gens qui ont je crois
du fait de leur éducation et de ce
qu'ils ont vécu dans le passé chevillée
au corps
à
patriotisme dont il semble bien qu'il
est aujourd'hui menacé peut être plus
que les lassos science de la jeunesse et
puis il y à la menace du mouvement
national républicain de bruno mégret à
villeurbanne pierre vial préparent la
bataille des municipales avec le même
programme que celui du front national
contre l'immigration donc comme
l'immigration égale vial contre
l'immigration et garder mes nerfs contre
l'immigration illégale malgré le fait
que en fonction tout simplement de l'âge
le pen c'est le passé et mais grâce à
l'avenir mais dans le rhône plusieurs
élus ont déjà claqué la porte du mnr ici
ce parti promettait de balayer le front
national il n'a fait que l'affaiblir
sans jamais réussir à s'imposer
l'avenir paraît bien sombre pour
l'extrême droite du sport du football il
reste encore dix jours avant la finale
de la coupe de france au stade de france
entre nantes et calais mais c'est déjà
l'affluence dans cette dernière ville
chez les supporters calaisiens vos
loyers pour tenir biais or les premiers
d'entre eux sont arrivés hier soir et
toute cette nuit ils ont fait la queue
pour être parmi les 5000 bénéficiaires
de ces fameux billet pour la finale
hier soir dans ce même stade de france
les petits entre guillemets slovènes ont
bien failli appliquer le théorème
calaisien ils ont mené 2 à 0 avant
d'être coiffé sur le poteau grâce au
coup de patte au double coup de pub de
david trezeguet les bleus champions du
monde devront en tirer des leçons et
s'est arrogé le maire le sélectionneur
de composer maintenant la liste des 22
sélectionnés pour le championnat
d'europe des nations
championnat qui commencera le 11 juin
commentaires florent gautreau depuis
plus d'un mois roger lemerre affirme
qu'il a en tête la fameuse liste des 22
joueurs sélectionnés pour l'euro 2000 la
victoire remportée hier in extremis
contre la slovénie a conforté le
sélectionneur dans ses choix
il s'appuiera sur le groupe champion du
monde et sur l'héritage d'aimé jacquet
autour de laurent blanc les anciens
restent les piliers de la sélection mais
la prime aux mondialistes s'applique
aussi aux plus jeunes qui ont eu la
bonne idée de revenir en forme au bon
moment
c'est le cas de trezeguet réalisateur
providentiel avec les bleus et de
thierry henry le serial buteur d'arsenal
sauf blessure 16 joueurs sont sûrs
d'aller fouler les pelouses de belgique
et des pays bas
à l'exception de ram et le deuxième
gardien tous les autres ont participé à
l'aventuré du mondial 98
il reste donc six places à prendre
quatre joueurs ont 90 % de chances
d'entrer dans les plans du sélectionneur
robert pirès pourtant très irréguliers
cette année bénéficiera sans doute de
laisser coupe du monde
les autres favoris sont les bordelais
johan micoud et sylvain wiltord qui ont
séduit roger lemerre en quelques
sélections
lionel letizi lui pourrait occuper le
poste de troisième gardien
il y aura forcément des déçus parmi ceux
qui ont 30 % de chances d'aller à l'euro
car mbeki ne joue jamais à madrid risque
de devoir laisser sa place aux
monégasques martin djetou qui peut jouer
défenseur ou milieu de terrain tony
vairelles qui rêve de revêtir la tunique
bleue en juin a le profil parfait du
remplaçant combatif et stéphane porato
essaiera de convaincre le maire malgré
une saison moyenne à l'om et puis il ya
tous les autres les joker qui devront
compter sur l'absence d'un titulaire ou
sur un coup de tête de roger lemerre
c'est le cas les deux champions de
france monégasque lamouchi et giuly mais
le plus gros point d'interrogation reste
nicolas anelka
il est capable de faire basculer
n'importe quelle rencontre mais ses
états d'âme madrilène et des blessures à
répétition pourrait bien l'empêcher
d'intégrer cette fameuse liste qui s'est
tant rêvée des lycéens coupe davis
féminine la fed cup la france a déjà
gagné sa rencontre face à la russie sans
vraiment et stud s'est imposé face à li
kobe de sahin et julie halard décugis ce
que vous découvrez sur ces images mais
emporté face à anna kournikova en trois
sets 6-2 2-6 6-1 et demain les
françaises seront opposés aux
australiennes
alors c'est dans l'essonne se tient
jusqu'à la fin de cette semaine le
festival international du film
scientifique 60 films sont présentés par
autant de pays une grande partie de ces
longs courts métrages ont été tournées
par les scientifiques eux mêmes dans ce
festival a parfois toutes les apparences
d'une célébration cannoise
mais les acteurs des films sont bien
différents un reportage patrice pollet
dernier mériaux
au festival du film scientifique d'orsay
l'ambiance ressemble à celle du festival
de cannes avec cependant une critique
différence ces acteurs se laisse diriger
moins facilement
la ville vient de faire une découverte
une guêpe est coincé à l'intérieur de ce
bout de moi et cherche un moyen de l'en
déloger
moins payés qu'à hollywood mais tout
aussi fascinant le genre animal assure
en grande partie le succès du film
scientifique le plus souvent les
cadavres de marcel sont découverts en
décomposition
la nature du développement des larves de
mouches sur les cadavres permettent
également de prouver les morts par
overdose de cocaïne et d'héroïne
agrandissant mille fois elle se déplace
à l'intérieur d'un décor pas plus grand
qu'un timbre poste
l'exploit c'est que la caméra s'y
promène comme sur un vrai plateau de
cinéma
hallucinante réunion de famille mais par
quel miracle les manchots arrive-t-il à
se retrouver
la réponse est dans ce film le tri
chaque manche au possède sa propre
fréquences vocales 60 films présentés
dont 20 en compétition
la science se bat pour se faire
connaître
cette image là il faut le défendre à
tout prix et pas essayer nécessairement
de faire de la pédagogie avec ce côté là
il ya un vrai besoin et il faut le
garder toujours notre civilisation a
besoin d'autre chose que d'enseignants
formel la musique par le son duvet et
que ça ne peut jouer facile entier dont
les images de plus en plus nombreuses
des images sont très belles dans ce
festival mais on peut aussi être trahie
par la technique mais festive et très
bien alors c'est nous arrivons à la fin
de cette édition je rappelle l'actualité
concernant la première grande réussite
mondiale en thérapie génique pour la
première fois un grave déficit
immunitaire qui obligeait de l'aider à
vivre dans une bulle a été corrigé les
bébés sont sorties vont bien nous en
avons parlé avec le professeur alain
fischer qui avec son équipe de l'hôpital
necker vient de réussir cette première
mondiale publiée dans la revue saion
c'est un encouragement notamment pour
tous ceux qui ont participé au téléthon
dans quelques secondes la météo avec
nathalie rihouet puis le point route
avec valérie maurice et leur attention
il ya eu un record de tuer la semaine
dernière sur les routes pour le week-end
de pâques prudence donc notamment pour
les retours il y aura ensuite envoyé
spécial le magazine présenté par paul
nahon avec deux reportages la new york
au sein d'une brigade d'élite de la
police new yorkaise et puis l'autre à
madagascar dans un gisement de diamant
où s'entassent 300000 personnes à 1h20
vous retrouverez florence duprat pour
dernier journal demain à 13h carole
gaessler et puis à 20h béatrice
schönberg qui recevra laurent fabius
alain dit bonsoir merci
je
et